this is stupid overlap between the two
that no one understands and the lack of
distinction between art and design and
art and non-art is so puzzling to people
and everybody wants to be an artist
because it in terms of status there's
almost nothing better you can you could
be in almost any culture basically
because art is terribly important as a
survival mechanism for any culture as a
result the people in primitive cultures
who can create art as such are those who
are highly respected and that basically
occurs in sophisticated cultures as well
but the only purpose of art is that it
is the most powerful instrument for
survival that art is so persistent in
all our cultures because it is a means
of the culture to survive and the reason
for that I believe is that art at its
fullest capacity makes us attendant but
if you look at a work of art you can
reengage reality once again and you see
the distinction between what you thought
things were and what they actually are
because of that it is a mechanism for
the species to survive and because of
that it is terribly important in human
consciousness I also believe that
curiously that beauty which is very
often something we confuse with art is
merely a mechanism to move us towards in
attentiveness you realize we all have a
genetic capacity and need to experience
beauty but beauty is not the ultimate
justification for art it is merely the
device by which we are led to
attentiveness
anyhow this is all very complex and I've
been thinking about it most of my life
and now I finally feel that I can
distinguish between what is art and what
is not and my distinction is if it moves
you to attentiveness it is art if it
doesn't it's something else
well you know the odd thing about us to
examine the art world so call and
examine the real where the art world is
concerned primarily with money and
status and that's linked to people's
need to elevate themselves and also to
invest in objects that will have a good
return of course that is not the
standard by which people really
interested in not with judge art and I'm
always amused by the definition of fine
art because I never knew what the word
find meant until I looked it up and
found out that fine as apply so art is a
term used in metallurgy it means that
you apply heat to metal of sufficient
intensity so that the impurities are
burned off well with that definition you
begin to understand something about the
subject and also you say well what are
the impurities of art what my belief is
that the impurities of art are
everything that does not contribute to
its function of producing attentiveness
and of course those impurities are
largely status and money and then you
look at what's reported and talked about
in the art world and it's always about
the money the leading issue that people
care about in the world of art is what
the Bernard so for 40 million dollars at
a time which broke old records and so
well who cares about what the bonod sold
for in terms of art that's one of the
impurities except that it is the focal
point and the central issue in art as it
is observed in our culture today
there have been a million encounters at
least but certainly one of them was when
a friend took me to the Frick I was 18
to show me the first period Villa
Francesca I've ever seen
and I almost fainted when I saw it and
that produced a lifetime of exploration
of Piero going all over the world
looking for Piero paintings and I think
finally having seen most of them
fortunately he did relatively few and
ending up doing a series of watercolors
and drawings based on the work of puro
it was sponsored by the Italian
government that was actually shown a few
years ago in Piero's home and sensor
poke row which has to be one of the
great things that could happen to anyone
who was as obsessed the silence